[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday [ __ ] May 22nd is that a record
for how quickly I said the f-word I'm
actually doing the podcast right now
riding in a car I'm not driving I'm on
my way to New York City because I have
to do some promotional stuff here for
efforts for family that's coming out I
this week right or next week May 30th I
don't know what so this begins Oh Billy
red face shown is freckle puss on
anything I can get myself on you know so
whatever I'm driving to New York and you
know something there's all this [ __ ]
traffic and I gotta take a early flight
tomorrow back to LA I don't have time
and my wife just sent me this whole
thing on what successful people do and
they date they [ __ ] you know they
don't know what they do they they know
how many minutes are in a day evidently
there's 1440 minutes in a day and they
use this wisely and they delegate right
they delegate [ __ ] like I don't want to
do that you know how to do that right
all right I'll pay you to do that you
know a small portion of what the [ __ ]
I'm making I got to get better at that
in order to delegate though what you
have to be is you have to be social and
you know that's not my thing unless I've
had a couple of drinks
other than that I'm kind of a curmudgeon
I don't know if you've noticed I'm a
little bit grumpy but uh [ __ ]
cruising now we're on the traffic go now
watch now this would be like a Thursday
when I thoughts gonna get to do the
whole hour so anyways I just got back
from my tour up there in Canada work
with Nate Craig who murdered it if you
don't believe me ask anybody who was in
Winnipeg Saskatoon and Regina and first
of all I'm very proud that Nate and I
did a show two shows in Regina and
neither one of us went with the easy
joke though we did the stupid it rhymes
with fun nobody's like vagina vagina
what's up with that I thought there was
going to be a giant [ __ ] hair sink hole
slash thing we kind of left it alone and
I don't we had a great time let's just
back it up here okay we start off and
Winnipeg I told the people in Winnipeg
that I wasn't going to tell people this
but I just think they're so off the
beaten path that's fine
the cuisine in Winnipeg is [ __ ]
insane all right Jesus what was the name
of that place we actually I didn't have
time to go this time I ordered from this
place the peasant something-or-other
where's my little list of places to go
scrolling down to Winnipeg I thought
there's going to be a bunch of traffic
he's just blocking me off the driver
here all right present kitchen get to
tourtière if you ever there t ort ie re
it's French
pork pie and then we went to the tallest
papi for breakfast the next day and I
wouldn't have known about either one of
those shout out to a Canadian by the
name of ed Robertson you might have
heard of him plays in a band I think
he's in a garage band or something like
that you might have heard of him I don't
know I'm just [ __ ] with you
so anyways the food was unbelievable up
there and the shows were awesome played
in this old theater and I forget the
name of I don't remember it's been
around since like 1900 and up top they
have like the the same old shitty seats
they used to have back when everything
was segregated you know and all the
white people with downstairs and anybody
else had to walk all the flights of
stairs to go upstairs you know and
what's the result what's the result
fifty years later white people are
getting their asses kicked in sports you
know why we got no quads we don't have
any gluts it's why our asses are so flat
we just used to walk into the theater we
were on the ground level and everybody
else had to walk up right that's why we
get our asses kicked from the gridiron
to the dojo stroke it all comes back to
going to see Harry Houdini and not
having to work for it so we were
actually there and it wasn't cold as
[ __ ] like the last time and you know
tried out some new stuff everything was
going great went to bed the first night
didn't have a drop of booze how about
that huh didn't smoke a cigar even
though there was Cuban cigars but you
know it's Canada so they got Cuban
cigars but there's no place to smoke
them they're very they're very hostile
against smokers or that just maybe like
overly protective
they sort of helicopter parent with
smokers up there and
you're sort of I guess allowed to do it
outside although I did not say I didn't
think I really saw anybody smoking
anywhere so anyways we did that gig and
the next one on the docket was we drove
up to sass Saskatoon oh speaking of
which there was these two or three
concept the Winnipeg show I thought they
were booing me but they were just going
to I don't know why we were in Winnipeg
I guess that's short for Saskatoon it's
like Cleveland the land up there I guess
they call it the tuna they just yell out
tune I have no [ __ ] idea but we
thought they were bored me so you know I
got upstage and I was just like Jesus
Christ man I thought that was a good
show you know but I was like no no no
they were yelling tune and like what's
to name is [ __ ] for Saskatoon I was like
alright we're in Winnipeg they're like
oh yeah sorry sorry that's a big thing
in Canada everybody's sorry I'm so sorry
like this waitress was clearing our
table and you know plate is empty and
when she goes to clear she goes oh sorry
sorry
it's like you're apologizing for do you
brought food to me now you're taking it
away and you're apologizing do it all
the time sorry I'm sorry
get the puck oh sorry so anyways we did
the drive up from
from Winnipeg to Saskatoon the one that
everybody was saying hey get ready what
the hell's that something Jesus that's
not pleasant is it I'm sorry sorry I
picked it up I'm gonna be ridiculously
Pleasant on this you know [ __ ] those
[ __ ] who yelled out tune in Winnipeg
sorry Sony was everyone Santa was gonna
be dreading that drive you know like an
eight-hour drive and so we start me and
they'd start driving up and we're just
hitting all these bugs and [ __ ] but I
got Titan man it was beautiful and both
loved the drive you know we live in LA
we're just smashed in with a zillion
other people it's nice to get out there
what a beautiful country Canada is good
Lord all these these farmhouses all of
this land it was beautiful no I just
kept thinking I would love to fly a
helicopter out here because if you had a
problem you can land it anywhere as
opposed to when I'm in LA I'm looking
for [ __ ] soccer fields and
playgrounds and hoping there's not kids
there if I ever had a problem and just
stopped there was just like just
wide-open spaces and I wasn't that bad a
drive we didn't like seven hours we took
the one lane highway instead of the two
lane highway so we had a lot of fun like
peeking around trucks and [ __ ] trying to
pass them a lot of farmers like driving
these giant tractors down the [ __ ]
Street you know I don't know I I got a
bunch of pictures of [ __ ] that I saw
every like every mile though there was a
barn that looked like it was gonna fall
down there'd be some guy who just had
like a zillion [ __ ] cars or tires or
something all piled up in his yard it
was really uh pretty interesting I was
just thinking those guys from gas monkey
you know if they ever pull all the
[ __ ] cars out of barns down in the
States they could just go up to Manitoba
and Saskatchewan they'd find I saw a
number I saw a 65 I'm driving like 70
miles an hour to when I still saw it so
65 Ford Galaxie I don't know if it was
the 500 might have been no I think was a
64 actually 64
I know I sound like the [ __ ] Rain Man
right now so anyway so then we get up to
[ __ ] SAS cat you want Saskatoon and
we only had one show that night so of
course I went out and got absolutely
[ __ ] hammered hammered at this bar a
lot of tattoos a lot of tattoos up in
Saskatoon a lot of tattoos sorry but it
was a beautiful town it had this amazing
Park and which I forget the [ __ ] name
of and I got up the next day coz I like
show him all those years I have in a
paper route like I can only sleep for so
[ __ ] long I just sort of naturally
wake up so you know I didn't get to bed
till like 2:00 in the morning I still
woke up in like 8:30 and I was staying
at that their [ __ ] red rum hotel
there it's this beautiful old hotel that
looks like you could have shot the
shining in there and it's right next to
this long Park and I just was watching
its gets a little mini waterfall I
watched these pelicans trying to fish I
saw some geese with some baby geese
walking around was crazy after all these
years of living in New York and LA I was
just sitting there geeking out there was
some old ladies standing there looking
at the goose the goose is like putting
its [ __ ] head down looking at her and
I'm thinking that's like an aggressive
posture so I walked away but I was also
looking sort of laughing like thinking
that goose was gonna [ __ ] the old lady
up and then thinking like what would I
do
cuz that would be bad I mean I can't
walk away from the old lady but I also
don't want to slap the [ __ ] out of this
goose in front of all of its children so
sort of a tense little moment there on
nature and fortunately cooler heads
prevailed and everybody went their
separate ways but deal I know the old
lady knew how close she came you know
she had a big grin on her face is the
thing was like duck and down low so
she's kind of ducking down like
imitating it you know what she's looking
at a gorilla and she's pounding her
chest and I thought for half a second
like I was going to see some like you
know
some [ __ ] old lady bird MMA action
you know but you know what she's so
[ __ ] old I bet she knows how to kill
a goose spray went out in the back here
and I do that [ __ ] they just walk up and
they grab it by the neck and then they
do the spin move and then they just hold
onto the necks of the body spins and it
just breaks the [ __ ] things neck she
looked like she was old enough that she
actually lived during those times you
know back when you earned your meal you
know like you knew the name of the thing
that you killed was like a pet right had
weird dreams probably slipped into your
[ __ ] sexuality somehow you like
dressing up like a bird when you [ __ ] or
something like that there's some weird
thing with anytime you get abused
you know violent sexy I don't know what
it is it ends up making you some weirdo
in the wreck so anyways I end up doing
that's why I walked up and I went over
that River there whatever the [ __ ] it is
like walking along these train tracks
and I got to be honest with you I was a
little nervous about that because it was
this old kind of wooden bridge and I was
just thinking huh every time someone
would walk by me you know I always kind
of made eye contact and like braced
myself because I just was nervous that
someone's just gonna grab my legs and
throw me over
never seen a movie a long time ago this
guy did that he was a psycho and he went
hiking with these people they didn't
realize he was a psycho
I think he'd already killed people then
he went up there and uh he went to like
take a picture this woman this couple of
somebody pushed both of him off the
[ __ ] cliff and it was so eerily done
but I'm like this has to be based on him
on a true story cuz usually that's not
good enough for Hollywood has to be some
dramatic way they kill you rather than
just some creepy real way so I was
walking across that that beautiful
nature and everything that I was just
you know worried someone's gonna just I
don't know just grab me by my ankles and
toss me right over before I realized
what it was going on you know typical
[ __ ] had it be so busy trying to save my
cell phone I wouldn't even think about
myself before I went over I think I
could have landed it though you know I
don't think I was that high up
[Music]
what does that say about me I'm going
through nature and thinking birds are
going to tack old ladies or something's
going to throw me off a bridge
[Music]
I'm just overly conscious cuz another
[ __ ] drivers listening here um anyways
plowing ahead here uh then we did the
drive down to Regina I don't really have
any we went to some [ __ ] bar why
don't know where the hell I was drinking
that's the same place I had lunch and I
[ __ ] went into when I was in
Saskatoon it's right right out front
from the from the Red Rum in that I was
staying at and oh my god that place was
a [ __ ] show
this is [ __ ] liars we walked into the
bar and the guy goes can I see your
driver's license I go yeah and then he
goes to scan the thing and I like
blocked it with my hand I go do don't
scan my ID where you go all you know
it's just for us bothering me but the
[ __ ] means which [ __ ] out of here you
would scan Nate so it's just like a like
just the liberties that people take with
your ID I don't let go of my ID anymore
let me see your ID and I just show I
hold on to when I go to take it as
Django just read it I don't get people
my ID you can look at it you can read it
you know I check into hotels they always
go to grab it for me and I hold on to it
and then the whole sorry sorry can I see
it I go I don't want you to type any
information into your you know oh we
just do that so the next time you stay
now you don't you take it and then you
sell it then someone else gets it and
then all my [ __ ] shits out there next
thing you know you know I don't know
what somebody defaults on a house and
[ __ ] Regina and the banks are coming
after me I don't know what I just know
it's not a good thing so we went in
there oh my god those people will
[ __ ] party it was it was some sort of
holiday weekend up there I don't know
what it was for but uh
a lot of tattoos a lot of tattoos a lot
of sleeves a lot of [ __ ] tattoos and
I just kept drinking and drinking and
drinking and I vaguely remember them
bringing a hockey stick over it was a
sherwoodk that blew my mind because I
had not seen one of those since I was a
kid you know and they did shots out of
it and I don't really remember much
after that I just went but I walked out
by myself I do remember that I think yes
then the next day I woke up and I did
the whole stupid walk and I was done
with the walk there was this little
double-decker bus and I was starving I
didn't know where there was a good
breakfast place and I just said [ __ ] it
and I walked up to the double-decker bus
that they turn into this [ __ ] little
restaurant thing and I had a hotdog for
breakfast and followed it up with a mint
chocolate chip ice cream cone and I sat
alone on a [ __ ] park bench eating an
ice cream cone Saskatoon Saskatchewan
hungover his [ __ ] and just laughing at
myself like what kind of a [ __ ] life
on my living so as I'm sitting there
this nice Canadian couple pulls up right
they both on bicycles one of them's
towing a kid
and I just see with the one guy you know
they're all like Flanders like that's
how nice they are up there and he just
goes he pulls up he's like oh no oh no
and I'm like what's he looking and I
turned around I looked back the you know
the little bus thing that had the hot
dogs in the ice cream and like 40
children she just showed up brought up
by like the teachers or something it's
like they were gonna be out of ice cream
and hot dogs by the time these people
ordered it was [ __ ] hilarious I beat
the rush just by like 30 seconds but
like they were just all know all geez
well I guess we got here at the wrong
time no no no sorry sorry it's okay it's
okay you eat everything
I don't need nourishment
they're like even apologetic like that
was so I always forget how loud and
obnoxious I am and my fellow Americans
are until I go to like other countries
like where I don't be the guy [ __ ]
on Americans because I was up there and
they just kept talking about how nice
the people are up there and I was like
dude [ __ ] these people they riot when
they when they lose you know a playoff
series okay they're just as races are
just as [ __ ] up blah blah by the time
we got to Regina I was like alright you
know what
these are really nice people I'll give
it to you I'll give it to you alright
I'm stopping I don't wanna be yet
another person that travels to another
country and then comes back here to tell
everybody how everything in this country
is wrong you should see how they make a
grilled cheese sandwich up there I mean
it's just so like everything's like
[ __ ] better it's like really is that
why everybody's always paying attention
to us you know if we stink so bad how
come you know the name of our president
and we don't know the name of your
president huh don't you think about that
one for a second
Janet Oh bill cuz you guys drop bombs on
us alright fair enough
[Laughter]
all right 17 minutes this is like the
[ __ ] old days right now if you'd like
to know I'm going over the Manhattan
Bridge
looking at my old digs way back in the
day up the street I used to live in
Yorkville I think that's what it was
called there was Rosa the depressing
[ __ ] Roosevelt Island Queensborough
bridge I walked across that thing one
time I was so sick of going to the gym I
was just like you know I ran down I
didn't run when I taught a [ __ ] walk
down walked over the bridge there's no
way to walk on a bridge and not think
about that Saturday Night Fever that
[ __ ] idiot you know a lot we was too
cowardly to get into that fight and then
he's going to do a headstand on the
Verrazano Bridge that's still by the way
that's the one in uh that goes from
Brooklyn to Staten Island
see if I still remember this goes
Brooklyn Bridge Manhattan Williamsburg
then Manhattan
hey sir is this the Brooklyn I mean
system Manhattan a Williamsburg Howard
Williamsburg house sorry Williamsburg my
fault so goes Brooklyn Manhattan
Williamsburg
Queensboro and then what the [ __ ] else
is up there there's some sort of
footbridge ish Triborough bridge or some
[ __ ] they probably renamed it you know
at this point it's not the Jackie
Robinson [ __ ] bridge it's probably
named after some some lady you know I
don't know what some lady you [ __ ]
show to climb on a show and she was
considered brave you know the hairy [ __ ]
Airy bridge looking like I don't do what
[ __ ] vagina joke her vagina now I'm
gonna do it on a bridge it's wrong with
me
so anyways oh my god Alphabet City yeah
now it's like all nice Tompkins Square
Park all the memories are coming back
you know I've been gone from this city
for so long that there's a lot of it
that I don't even recognize like I mean
obviously the Empire State Building and
that type of [ __ ] Times Square and that
type of thing but it's like just a
completely different from the city that
I moved to like Times Square was [ __ ]
scary when I moved here
so we just drove by Ted just drove bias
and was driving like 30 miles an hour
with the sunroof open with their cell
phone out the top video taping I get
some podcasting but I'm not driving
right aw do you want to film it on sorry
sorry it's okay sorry I'll let it it for
you I won't charge or anything I'm
Canadian
um how funny is it that they're that
nice and then you get them out on the
ice that's when it all comes out right
[ __ ] cross-checking to the neck
I was said Flanders gets his glasses off
puts on a different kind of sweater and
you better keep your [ __ ] head up
that's Canada right
Kansai please do a drawing of [ __ ]
Flanders as a [ __ ] of good for the
[ __ ] I don't know the Thunder Bay
lamas whatever whatever the name of your
teams are up there in the [ __ ] lower
levels the minor leagues whatever you
called
well maybe every [ __ ] Canadians it's
a I made it to Thunder Bay and I didn't
I wasn't good enough to get the NHL so I
tried to fight my way into the lake I
know I'm doing a bad Canadian accent I
apologize but uh anyways what happens
when I remember a long time ago Jeff
Ross hosted a comedy show live from
Thompson Square Park
and I remember thinking that was so
[ __ ] bad-ass anybody that was
performing there cuz alphabet see like
before I even came here
people were saying how scary that wasn't
like Thompson Square was just like the
city had just given in to like I mean it
was like that's a subway go by if you
hear something it was just like a tent
city like I walked by it one time and it
was just like I was trying to mask the
fear in my face plus the a rubberneck
and just wanted to see what it looked
like and it was like junkies homeless
people just [ __ ] mentally ill people
it was like it was like the beginning of
a bad like hair metal video you know
when they so try to do those apocalypse
once they're all basically loosely based
on the scape from New York people coming
up on a manholes even what's his face
did that Michael Jackson did it look
what was like the Thriller video
except you know it was real ghetto work
um anyways I'm gonna read some
advertising here at the risk of getting
carsick it was funny about having a kid
is your screen savers all become your
kit and every time you pick up your
phone you just you know you're around
other adults and they have no idea
you're looking at your kid you just got
ball then you try to turn into a
coughing oh oh excuse me because it's a
man you're not allowed to show love um
all right content live reads okay here
we go
ah look at this look at this live from
the [ __ ] Williamsburg Bridge it's old
zip
Bruder drivers going to come nuts are
you hiring well are you do you know
where to post your job to find the best
candidates talk about the challenge of
finding great talent in or the
importance of finding great talent to a
successful business so I think people
know that yeah you can't you guys didn't
know you know when you're hiring people
you don't want to [ __ ] [ __ ] the
comment especially if they're running
the register you know or your new CEO
you don't want to dope you want the best
person possible so be nice if you could
you can pick from you know hundreds of
thousands of people rather than whatever
mouth-breather answers your ad in the
local paper how's it recruiter is
different with zip you could post your
job to 100 plus job sites with just one
click then they're powerful technology
efficiently matches the right people to
your job better than anyone else that's
why zip recruiter is different unlike
other job sites it doesn't depend on
candidates finding you that one was
creepy that was like a ghost went by it
finds them in fact over 80% of jobs
posted on zip recruiter get a qualified
candidate just 24 hours that's how great
this is and that's how desperate people
are no juggling emails or calls to your
office simply screen rate nice tits and
manage candidates all in one place with
zip recruiters easy-to-use dashboard
call to action find out today wise it
has been used by all businesses of all
sizes to find the most qualified
candidates with immediate results right
now my listeners can post jobs on zip
recruit for free that's right for free
oh that's right for free sorry we're
driving sorry just go to zip recruiter
comm slash bird that zip recruit calm
slash / one more time hey try it for
free go to zip
[ __ ] recruiter calm / / sorry that
was my bad New York accent hey I'm zip
recruiting over here alright car shield
I have no idea what this is is this a
bra for the front of your car so you
don't get rocks up on it sooner or later
your car will break down it's a fact
every car truck and SUV owner knows if
you're lucky it happens while still
under the manufacture manufacturer's
warranty and the repairs are covered if
it happens after the warranty expires oh
ho ho ho you could be out of pocket
thousands to get it fixed that's why
getting extended coverage from car
shield calm is a good idea a new engine
our new transmission could cost over
$5,000 transmission doesn't cost $5,000
all right you can go on youtube to
figure out a [ __ ] Pullen engine you
could do it
even a simple reparative sensor can cost
over a thousand dollars get that hassle
man car shield makes the whole process
like that Canadian whole process process
sorry easy you select your favorite
mechanic or you can even go to the
dealership to do the work that's cool
and there's no checks in the mail stuff
or waiting for reimbursement car shield
gets the mechanic paid directly car
shields and administrators even give you
VIP treatment providing 24/7 roadside
assistance and a rental car while you're
yours is in the shop so you're not left
stranded out in the cold or you guys
could maintain the [ __ ] engines it's
funny engine blocks made out of [ __ ]
steel so it's the transmission if you
just keep it lubed up I mean
theoretically it can't last forever but
who knows who's kidding who you're not
going to [ __ ] do that are you so get
car shield if your car is 3 to 12 years
old it doesn't mean you have to pay high
repair bill Bill's car shield
administrators have paid out close to 2
billion in claims and they're ready to
help you save yourself thousands in
potential car repairs get covered by the
ultimate and extended vehicle service
protection before it's too late
visit car shield comm / / - save 10%
that's car shield calm / / - save 10% a
deductible may apply and a bunch of
other [ __ ] be careful with those guys
man there's always some [ __ ]
their extended warranties maybe they're
the good guys
all right upside how many more these
goddamn things are there two more two
more and then I can start people
watching like I used to do back in the
day and [ __ ] all over everybody all
right there's a better way for you to
buy business travel it's called upside
calm every time you buy a trip it upside
I'm just reading this fast so I get
through it
you'll save your company a ton of money
and they give you amazon amazon gift
card worth hundreds of dollars
upside upsides able to do this because
they bundle your flights and hotel
together for one low price bundling
pricing saves money god damn it if
you're a frequent business traveler your
company saves a ton of money and you get
thousands of dollars a year in gift
cards just think of how many hookers you
can get when you fly over to Thailand
just for buying your air and hotel
together an upside plus you still get
all your miles man if you're shopping
for business travel you'd be crazy not
to check out upside comm crazy I don't
about crazy but you know probably
foolish it takes just three minutes to
see how much you can say by buying your
flights and hotel together for one low
price and right now you can use my name
per your and you're guaranteed to get at
least a $100 trip one outside $100 trip
yet oh [ __ ] at Burger King $100 Amazon
gift card for your first trip that's my
name Barbie you are are to get at least
$100 Amazon gift card say big on travel
and get a big gift card every trip
evidently I love upside calm even though
I've never used it upside calm minimum
purchase required C for complete details
all right here we are graffiti graffiti
New York somebody wrote Elvis for some
goddamn reason oh let me get some New
Yorkers here where are they we got a red
light all right stamps calm everybody I
use stamps calm just I'm coming off the
bridge by the way all right coming off
the bridge I use stamps calm to send out
anytime I'm whoring myself out to send
out my posters stamps saves you time and
money which you can use that time to
help grow your business I can mail any
letter any package using just my
computer and printer and the mailman
picks it up avoid the hassle man of post
office and mail everything from
postcards to envelopes to packages
domestic or international create your
stamps account in minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no long term
Commitments click print mail and you're
done unlike the post office dance calm
never closes print postage for your
letters or packages at your convenience
24/7 seven days a week
key words to describe it or any bit dev
identity a convenient easy reliable
flexible dirty-ass New York look at
these [ __ ] people oh my god kids
playing outside in New York unsupervised
a little kid acting like he had a gun
this is like the old New York I know
this is going to be all like [ __ ]
high-end now is that's not a crazy guy
that's an artist who's he talking to
himself Robins sold gold cash we buy
gold is a no lonely asian looking woman
they're leaning up against a dirty pole
the [ __ ] am i OS extreme and Delancy I
never used to be down here all right
convenient easy reliable flexible right
now you can enjoy the stamps services
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale about long-term
commitments go to stamps calm click on
the microphone on top of the homepage
and type in birbee you are that stamp
commenter burr stamps calm never go to
the post office again
alright down here like a round Houston
Street back in the day I used to do this
[ __ ] room called surf reality and it
was the beginning of the alt seat and
the level of talent this is before you
could start your career start a
privileged career in the [ __ ] all
rooms where there was like no heckling
let's just support and give somebody at
least 20 minutes to get to a [ __ ]
punchline this was like Club comics
going down there and then just some
weirdo people that you know just were
just totally different but all the
comics loved them and I used to do a
place down here called surf reality and
I remember every time I go up to train
and I walked over here I used to [ __ ] I
was convinced I was going to get mugged
and I bought this jacket from the
army-navy store and a black [ __ ] hat
trying to look like I was in Nam or some
[ __ ] and you know keeping my head down
so they didn't see the [ __ ] Ron
Howard look on my goddamn face you know
you know what's great about this is as I
look out this I might be able to do a
whole podcast and not bring up what is
happening to my Boston Celtics Jesus
Christ everything that I feared finally
happened I told you guys when I first
started watching I'm like how could a
team that doesn't really have a center
that doesn't rebound is not good playing
D in the paint and lives and dies by the
three how can you win in the NBA but
they did and I bought into it and you
know what a big bucket of reality hits
in the game of steal right there Fred I
don't know if game 3 is tonight but
after watching Game two
Jesus Christ I was so exciting at the
number one pick next year I'm gonna go
out on a limb and say maybe we should
get a center what are you guys thinkin
man you still believe in Kelly Olynyk
if the rest of the team can somehow get
us to Game seven
I'm warning you people in Cleveland
right now you better watch out for Kelly
Olynyk that is a bad man in game seven
games one through six he's [ __ ]
horrific but you get that man to game
seven lucky seven that's a lot that's
what I call lucky seven with this Kobe
Elevens brings the Celtics to have in
some [ __ ] I don't know if it rhymes it's
true I don't know
after Game two I'm wondering if we're
even gonna make it to Game four I mean
we lost by fifty four [ __ ] points
that's like some [ __ ] that happens when
you're like in middle school
butthis there's a part of me that
actually enjoys this because I'm rootin
against the Warriors and I think it bugs
LeBron and the Cavaliers that we were
the number one seed I think it bugs in
that they acted like we even remotely
had a shot against them and I know
Isaiah's hurt we just found that out but
come on he's hurt so what we only lose
by 34 points I think they just got a
chip on the shoulder to the defending
champs and nobody is talking about them
like they are and everybody's up the
[ __ ] ass you know though the Boston
Celtics who their number one seed just
trying to sell this series right
everybody's out there talking about the
[ __ ] the filthy Golden State Warriors
kicking people in the balls and blowing
out [ __ ] ankles and [ __ ] I mean has
it been a more boring Western Conference
or Eastern Conference matchups I mean
these things have just been absolutely
blowouts I bet they callin up Stern
again and he's going to get those
mobbed-up reps and then if I can start
fixing some games again just so they
don't lose out on all this ad money
because these things are just going to
go they're going to go four games rather
than having 14 games possibly have ad
money they're going to have the bare
minimal eight you know and these owners
man they got a lot of money they have to
pay out to these players you know they
spend a lot of money with their hookers
and all that type of [ __ ] you know
getting their [ __ ] tummies tucked lap
band surgery and all the ship getting
their faces yanked back so they can keep
banging the underpaid cheerleaders or
whatever it is that they do so everybody
I'm everybody's just basically waiting
for the finals and I don't know man
I don't want to jinx it I'm gonna shut
up because I already jinx the [ __ ]
city of Washington
by just saying I don't want to jinx it
but uh I think I'm not gonna say what's
gonna happen I'm say what I would love
to see I want to see the Cavaliers win I
want to see them go [ __ ] back-to-back
and I want to see that [ __ ] dream
team of I don't know I can't say a bunch
of free agents just I don't I'm just all
kunti because I wanted to see the
[ __ ] I wanted to see the Thunder see
if they could get by him I didn't want
to see the [ __ ] one of the best guys
just join the goddamn team um can you
imagine that like back in the day you
know like when Larry Bird steals the
ball from Isiah can you imagine the next
year like Isiah Thomas was a Celtic then
we just like kick the [ __ ] as a [ __ ]
guy staring at me like why I'm doing
this recording right now I just waved in
and he continued to stare at me and now
I'm feeling like now I'm feeling weird
oh I guess he was looking at the car
it's sunglasses on Jesus Christ
is this guy a [ __ ] robot why is he
looking at me
he's got a minivan and you just stare
I'm in a SUV I guess if you have a
minivan you [ __ ] you take your
sunglasses off to look at an SUV right
the minivan is sort of the ball 'us SUV
and the SUV sort of the one ball like I
don't know a full-size truck I know how
it works I'm not a redneck I'll [ __ ] day
The Handmaid's Tale on Hulu is anybody
watching that I came home the other day
my mother-in-law she always she watches
all these shows that I would never see
she started to watch one about it was
about this girl who committed suicide
and left like a tape and she was
watching that one that was like it's
like Little House in the Prairie meets
like an S&M do was really weird I don't
know what was going on like they would
they like these nuns and they were
trying to escape this thing and one of
them makes it on the subway and the
other one doesn't and then next thing
you know they got her tied down and
they're beating her feet how do you get
that job the official like feet beater I
could see like back in the day you know
to me back in the well maybe this was
but now this seems to be like in the
future do you realize that there's
people out there that they're born and
at some point when they try to figure
out like what am I good at like the
answer to that ends up being torturing
other human beings how [ __ ] up is that
you know what I mean just like
it's kind of like being like a comedian
either funnier you know you can't teach
somebody to be funny and then there's
like like torture and stuff you just
can't teach somebody to be able to do
that just like block it out if
somebody's [ __ ] scream and this light
you've seen this screaming and crying
the guys just just whacking the [ __ ] out
of her feet always come always a smile
on like the Jesus crying what the [ __ ]
what the hell you're watching she always
left she's like I don't know I just put
this on alright so here we are Jesus
Christ you know I gotta give it up to
the graffiti artists like they've really
taken it to another level you know in
certain tattoos I've noticed you know
there's like that the high level tattoo
artists are amazing but the problem is
is most people that get tattoos don't
have a lot of money so like you know
it's the worst is when you see somebody
go into a tattoo parlor and they're
looking at [ __ ] on the wall it's just
like dude that's gonna be on your body
for life you don't even have like if you
don't have an idea you know the theme
let's see I don't know kind of like a
butterfly with like a bee and that's
what's gonna end up happening if you
look on a wall it's either gonna be a
skull what's that star tattoo that
everybody has that red and [ __ ] black
one I don't like three comedians that
have them a couple of boy band guys have
them I don't know what it is maybe it's
an anime thing I have no idea that's my
new word anime cuz I'm watching that
[ __ ] one punch man anyways let's get
back to the Celtics holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
you realize we have lost
I think we've lost my like a total of
like like north of 80 points in the
first two games
definitely north to 70 like if you took
all the if you just had the Cavaliers
win by one in Game one and then one in
Game two and you just gave him all those
other points like they would not they
could have me in there
I was kidding no me you got me in there
for about a quarter and a half it's all
tired up 78 78 um Jesus Christ I mean
this is like one of this is the worst
beating a Celtic team has ever taken in
my life in the playoffs the other
closest most humiliating one to this was
I don't know a lot of people don't
remember this during the Larry Bird era
and it was the last year of Bill Fitch
he'd kind of lost the team I guess
they'd blame the coach I don't know how
but we got swept by the Milwaukee Bucks
and I remember we lost Game one and we
lost Game two and then we lost Game
three I just kept thinking like they're
going to turn it on they're going to
turn it on and then they lost Game four
and that team had Larry Bird Robert
Parish Kevin McHale I don't think we had
Dennis Johnson at that point and I'm
trying to remember who was on the Bucs
was Sidney Moncrief I don't know who
else
dude I'm so psyched that I already got
40 minutes of this [ __ ] podcast done
because I have no goddamn time like I
was supposed to be this thing that I'm
doing I was supposed to be there 25
minutes ago it's 5:55 it's supposed to
start at 6:30 so there is some PA right
now freaking the [ __ ] out and there's
nothing I can do about I'll look at this
I'm on Houston Street another fire in
just this is just like the fire chief
he's got like a pickup truck
now they got a fire engine there by the
way dude do you see that [ __ ] lunatic
which is plowed into the all those
people in Times Square what the [ __ ] is
wrong with people
Jesus I don't want to like talk about
its give anybody [ __ ] ideas let's get
off that subject all the adidas store
I love adidas always been an adidas guy
I don't mind Nike you know I like it I
was like that deed is better you know
why because no one knew like everyone
knew what deed is before Nike came along
its night Nike I don't know what it is
oh wow look at this this is down here
the old [ __ ] IO subway stop when I
used to live on the Upper East Side I
used to come down and go to the Comedy
Cellar and the Boston Comedy Club what
the faster place that's what I used to
get off that's when I started looking up
all the names of these people like who
they what is Astor Place and I found out
about the Astor family and yeah they
just all just bunch of [ __ ] slum
Lords all the statues I just started
looking him up learned about the
Triangle Shirtwaist Fire people jump
into their [ __ ] deaths cuz somebody
locked the door to the look that one up
to Triangle Shirtwaist Fire actually
read a book on it and uh it was just I
don't know why I did it was it was the
most uncomfortable book since I read I
read the book the perfect storm and
[Music]
if you don't buy the book just [ __ ]
open it up and just there's a chapter
maybe like a three page thing maybe
where the guy describes what happens
when you drowned and it's just like I
don't know a [ __ ] blood goes cold man
it's [ __ ] freaky hell do you know
whatever they find those guys in the
caves they always have this goofy smile
on their face like those divers decide
to [ __ ] swim into a goddamn cave and
just then what I love they're dumb
enough to do that and then some poor
bastard has to go in there has to go in
there and try to [ __ ] find him why
don't they just leave him why don't they
just leave him down there what the [ __ ]
I don't understand you know what I mean
just [ __ ] leave him down there why
did he spend all that money to go get he
swam into a cave he went into a cave
underwater like what the [ __ ] are we
supposed to do and that somebody's
goddamn jump they got to go down and
fish you going down there
no one you're gonna see a dead body when
they find him I guess they always have
this goofy smile on their face because
the last thing is your body releases I
don't all this dopamine or some [ __ ] I
sound like Joe Rogan right now except I
don't know what I'm talking about
dopamine and you know one of those drugs
that those [ __ ] ravers take releases
that [ __ ] right
and they feel this this level of
euphoria like the end of your life level
of euphoria and then the next day they
just eaten like a bowl of Apple Jackson
they like just burst out in tears
because it's so [ __ ] depressing
because they [ __ ] up they already know
what it feels like to die which
evidently after you go through the
horror a little walk on the water guess
it's a nice experience like a man that
wasn't that bad
this driver thinks I'm out of my [ __ ]
mind I know it uh where we got 44
minutes 44 [ __ ] minutes oh Jesus I
used to go down here and I used to do
hot 97 you know back in the day when
everything was [ __ ] crazy
like three times a year rappers would
seem to have like a gunbattle in the
[ __ ] lobby and I would go down there
whenever I was doing uh whenever I was
doing Caroline's you know and I used to
headline Caroline's on like a Tuesday
night and they would have Lois fur and
ax they used to have to pull the [ __ ]
curtain you know so it wouldn't look bad
and I was doing talents rooms and so
it's doing the white in the black room
so I used to come down here and I used
to try to get some people that maybe saw
me open for talent or Drew Frasier a
[ __ ] Gerald Kelly the New York Kings
Rob Stapleton all of them I used to do
that rooms
one of the most fun times in my career
that I had was was doing that stuff
nobody knew who the [ __ ] I was I had to
go on stage you know expect now people
come out they know who I am so then it's
like I have to work to lose him but back
then I actually had to [ __ ] earn it
and you know believe me I I look back on
those days fondly but I don't I don't
miss not selling tickets so whenever I
come back here I always think about all
of those gigs Capone used to have this
room
Nell's on 14th Street it was the
greatest [ __ ] bar but it was such a
hard room for me that one in lebar bet
talent had that one and that one that
[ __ ] room every time I went there it
was like I bond next time I killed I
bombed I killed and I could never figure
that room out was like an after-work
party and I just would go up there white
as hell and it just either they you know
yeah basically in the black rooms you
have you have you're open and joking and
that's it they let people have their
very much like Sicilians where it's like
you're dead to them you [ __ ] up once
that's it you're dead to me over this is
this relationship is done and there's no
there's no there's no repairing it which
is why it's amazing
what's-her-face the Fuji chick there
started to get booed on the Apollo and
then [ __ ] turned it around the hell's
our goddamn name
you know amazing voice cute his health
for hours late to her shows Lauryn Hill
Lauryn Hill whenever I hear the Fuji
music that reminds me when I first moved
down here that in lieu tank Lane 36
chambers and what else the what else was
i listening to back then I don't know
okay now if this guy's driving like a
[ __ ] maniac I think he's sick of my
podcast here um how far away are we
another five minutes you know they're
freaking out man oh what a [ __ ] is here
I'm going to hotel first yeah I got a I
look like a I look like I just came from
Saskatchewan they're gonna take pictures
so I can't be looking like that I got to
look like at least bathe today um oh
dude I had a [ __ ] 6:30 a.m. flight
today oh not that puts me in a goddamn
mood my show didn't get done till twelve
of course I had to go out and have a
couple of pops to celebrate the end of
the tour I want to thank everybody who
seriously who came out in Winnipeg
everybody that came out and told
Saskatoon
sorry about the popping on the piece
here and everybody that came out Regina
I had a great time I'm definitely those
three cities are now part of my tours
now I feel I can go right across the
whole southern part so I was telling
people next thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna do do Alaska over to Yellowknife
and some other ones Jesus Christ
[ __ ] nine-foot lady with no clothes
on you see that
she had her ass hanging out of the
bottom of her [ __ ] dress like a sand
trap somebody [ __ ] divots in it sorry
sorry I'm sorry um not to that many
prize that we stopping to get gas no we
try to make a left
okay sorry these cars broken yeah let's
go let's go we get behind the one polite
cab driver in the [ __ ] City here
three RevoluSun why these people wearing
scarves it's not even cold out
absolutely not exactly you mean the left
we're going left here that idiot
yeah I like you me like me you just [ __ ]
on everybody to driving them [ __ ] so I
did only in specially Sunday you got
it's like Jurassic Jurassic Park forgive
you what I love what you say and trash
more but make it more entertaining it
makes me feel more normal because that's
all I do
don't you think part of it is because we
feel like you know they don't know what
we're doing we're too wrapped up in
ourselves or do you think they're morons
when you're right and and then the 99
people is wrong they makes you we're
right there you go yeah that makes you
right I love it
I'll look at that Bill's barn burger
oh there's some flier fan in there with
a Clojure oof Claude Giroux ever you say
it's [ __ ] name okay right here
alright dude I'm gonna jump out and I'll
be all wrong
all right I'm just gonna I'm gonna I'll
be calm be back down and like I'll be so
good at this I don't think that's a
place for me you up to circle yeah so I
think you've got my phone number right I
just I think I texted you did you touch
me let me call you now yeah call me now
so then I got it and you call me I'll
show in the front okay cool all right
you know I'm gonna call these people and
I'll let them know that I'm coming over
I don't know what why the [ __ ] do I have
to be in an hour early for a goddamn
podcast
I gotta warm up my voice [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] right um I saw your phone ring
it's my phone ringing these are you know
that's not me somebody's saying hello
unless we're in that [ __ ] movie with
the guy from Beretta
you ever see that movie the guy who
killed somebody or maybe killed somebody
got out of jail he played beretta
remember they call them the guy who did
like twin peaks' or something come on
you know that not Mulholland Drive
what's it what's sick remember the guy
from beretta don't go to bed with a
price on your head no Anna Coren don't
do it hey why don't you give me your
phone and I'll do it
oh you know I don't see my number here
no it's not 3-1 oh come here just give
me the cadion yes this quicker why do
you have one glove on no I'm driving
I'll let you drive a glove I like
Michael Jackson that I'm doing I use the
left hand moves right with Michael
Jackson I love it
you got friends you got Frank you know
something I actually think he did too
you know what yeah you can't [ __ ]
blessed a bunch of white kids even if
you became white yeah and get off on it
twice but California couldn't they
couldn't nail down OJ right they just
want to work boom is a replication
better they just want alright haven't
said that would you leave would you
would you if you had a kid I know if you
have kids you wouldn't leave with
Michael though right
now they're all there cuz I could fight
him off I'm gonna Park on that side so
you can feel free take all your time
I'll be right here he just pull up to
your house huh
right stomping his foot and your [ __ ]
kids gotta go up I gotta hit pause on
this I'll do the last eight minutes
later all right
bags do I need a what pack your bag
thank you to the back oh yeah that's
where my that's where my show closer a
nice all right help me yeah there's like
regular clothes and then this headlining
close I got to get on my head pointing I
luckily I okay alright okay I'll talk to
you guys in a minute
alright I'm back I'm back oh freckled
[ __ ] oh is back here I did all my press
that I had to do I want to thank
everybody over at vulture fest everybody
treated me great I had a fun time going
back and forth one of the women over
there was giving me [ __ ] about how bad
the Celtics were playing and you know
and I was just agreeing with her and
that she just kept trying to do a dig on
the Celtics and I go you know I really
don't appreciate your little
passive-aggressive comments on the
Celtics I'm admitting that you're
kicking her ass and then she laughed go
now you caught that so I go you know
what part of Ohio you're from and she
goes oh I'm not from Ohio I go way to
meet you know from Ohio how you a
Cavaliers fan she goes I'm a LeBron fan
I might get the [ __ ] out it she goes
yeah and I was a fan of his when he went
down to Miami and I'm a fan now that
he's gone back to Cleveland it's just
like you know found out she's from
Washington DC I'm like you're a [ __ ]
Wizards fan she goes oh I don't want to
do that it's just you know I actually
respect it on some level
I think that she's a UH you know if I
guess you're all going to be free agents
and piling on with each other then you
might as well be like a free agent fan
then it doesn't [ __ ] matter right I
don't know I don't know what it's bro
I'm just joking around we had a great
time giving each other's [ __ ] and then I
got to sit down they it was pretty cool
they actually showed the first episode
of season 2 from what I heard people
really liked it of course was not in the
room I didn't want to deal with that and
and then we went and we did a I went and
I did the interview in front of the
crowd that just saw it and handed out
some free t-shirts we had these these
condoms made up f is for family condoms
and stuff handed them out people like
those took some pictures afterwards this
great interview
you know just great questions and that
type of thing was a lot of fun and
knocked it out so Oh Billy Boy is gonna
be hittin the [ __ ] hotel bahía soon
how much time I get left here I got a
knock out another [ __ ] five minutes I
might do it tomorrow morning maybe I'll
do that you know cuz it doesn't make a
difference because you guys I gotta
watch the Celtics man how much are they
down by alright watch even how to turn
on a TV anymore watch now yes that's
what I want to do I want to watch now I
want to watch now you want to watch now
I want to watch TV
setting the world on fire how much are
we down by kelly olynyk for the love of
god pretend it's fourth quarter game
seven whatever the [ __ ] it is you have
to do alright come on alright this is
football
you guys really gonna listen to me
channel stuff you don't hear this [ __ ]
I'm gonna watch the goddamn game and I
know dude live commentate alive I'm not
doing that someone's just sit here
watching these people getting the
[ __ ] [ __ ] kicked out of them
Isaiah's out I mean we could potentially
get like 40
oh my god all of a sudden just having
the number one draft pick just seems a
lot different I knew all these [ __ ]
people go on like I'll tell you right
now the Celtics are only a player way I
was at least smart enough to say it
we're more like a player and a half away
I thought meaning we needed two players
remember a few months ago what they were
trying to suggest if we got Carmelo
Anthony like we'd have a legitimate shot
to take out [ __ ] I almost said the
LeBron James the Cavaliers but that's
really what it is I don't think we do it
so I'm gonna watch this game this
podcast is going to be like I owe you
three minutes okay
I'd really don't because I've done a
bunch of over an hour but um I got to
upload this [ __ ] I got an early flight
because I got to go out and get back to
my wife and daughter that's it thank you
guys for listening and please tell
everybody on May 30th that f is for
family is coming out and I'm gonna be
doing a bunch of press so I apologize if
you see my stupid face a little bit too
much out there I have to do it I got to
put on the monkey sad monkey hat a
little [ __ ] you know do my little
[ __ ] dance and over the next couple
of weeks but um you know we'll be trying
to I don't about be trying to let you
guys know where I'm gonna be at if you
give a [ __ ] alright that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check in on ya on
Thursday